einstein ist zurück das glaubt
jedenfalls die harvard university
ok wiedergeburt ist jetzt nicht das was
vermutet wird aber es gibt eine
wissenschaftlerin und sie ist noch sehr
jungen einem physiker sind die alle in
den schatten stellt und sie bricht jetzt
schon alle rekorde sammler cottbus
passiert ski baute mit 14 jahren ein
flugzeug und zwar einen richtigen zu
ihrem vater so diese mmc in rekordzeit
physik mit bestnote markiert ihren
doktor an der harvard university und
dass unser ganz besonderen
rahmenbedingungen klicks um seite
fiction über die neue einstein herzlich
willkommen
ja ich will sowieso davon überzeugt
dass frauen in der wissenschaft
systematisch unterdrückt wurden sie
wurden tot geschwiegen ignoriert an den
rand gedrängt wer weiß heute schon
dass vilja -7 fleming das system zur
stern katalogisierung entwickelt hatte
das aus dem wasserstoff anteil in ihrem
spektrum basierte und damit 10.000
sterne katalogisierte wie es die
entdeckerin von hunderten sternen gab
nehmen und norway oder marie curie eine
der wenigen frauen die mit einem
nobelpreis ausgezeichnet wurde
tschuldigung mit 2 1 sie bekam 1903 den
nobelpreis für physik und 911 den
nobelpreis für chemie
wie war der erste mensch der 2 nur
weltreise erhalten hat damals gab es
übrigens an deutschen universitäten so
insgesamt rund 1500 studenten kurz zuvor
dürften die noch gar nicht studieren
heutzutage sind knapp 50 prozent der
studienanfänger studentinnen und auch
beim abschluss ist der anteil bei knapp
50 prozent aber dann treten wieder
verhältnisse aus dem vorigen
jahrhundert 1 44% der doktorarbeiten
sind von frauen 39 prozent der
wissenschaftlichen mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter sind frauen 24 prozent wird
immer weniger derjenigen in die
habilitieren also eine arbeit um
professoren zu werden schreiben den
frauen 18 prozent der stellen für
professorinnen und professoren sind dann
von frauen gesetzt und bei den topf
stellen sind immer noch mal weniger 13,6
prozent also auch heute noch werden
frauen im wissenschaftsbetrieb
systematisch benachteiligt gefühlt zum
beispiel eine studie zu mündlichen
prüfungen im fach jura
während abiturientinnen im schnitt
genauso wie abiturienten also beim
abschneiden ist das bei der jura
abschlussprüfung anders und zwar
seltsamerweise vor allem in der
mündlichen prüfung forscher 2014 die
abschlussprüfung ab oberlandesgericht
hamm ausgewertet in dieser studie hatten
die frauen sogar die besseren abi noten
schnitten aber vor allem in den
mündlichen prüfungen die nicht wie die
klausuren analysiert waren schlechter ab
an der harvard business school werden
die mündlichen prüfungen übrigens
verschriftlicht und anonymisiert seitdem
schneiden baut studentin gleich gut ab
die studenten seltsam dann ist da die
meldung über die einstein an wichtig
sabina gonzalez pastörs die scheint
die wissenschaftliche turbo karriere
hinzulegen west note 5 am massachusetts
institute of technology in physik
studium für das sie nur drei jahre
gebraucht hat und jetzt macht sie ihren
doktor und zwar nicht an irgendeiner uni
sondern an der harvard university ihre
fachgebiete wie übrigens auch meine
lieblingsthemen schwarze löcher
raumzeit gravitation und hier speziell
die krankenkasse station sieht also
offenbar überall dahin wo es wirklich
interessant ist und auch wirklich
komplizierte dabei hatte sie vorher mit
den gleichen problemen zu kämpfen wie
wohl jede frau sie wurde unterschätzt
und am mpi und in harvard abgelehnt da
war sie allerdings noch nicht
volljährig aber genau dieser ehrgeiz
scheint sie auszuzeichnen
deswegen wird sie jetzt auch ziemlich
umworben die nasa würde sie gerne
einstellen und auch amazon gründer jeff
bezos würde sie gerne bei seinen
raumfahrtprojekte dabei haben aber es
scheint so dass sie eher in der
theoretischen physik forschen wird und
dort astrophysik ihr fach wird wird oder
eben quantenphysik oder oder oder
vielleicht wird sie sogar auf mehreren
fachgebieten aktiv da ist ja nicht
ausgeschlossen einer neuen einstein ist
dazu zu kommen
viele erwarten von ihr nicht mehr und
nicht weniger als dass die bahnbrechende
erkenntnisse gewinnen wird kaspersky
lässt das allerdings kein zitat ein
theoretiker der sagt er wird in einem
bereich bahnbrechende erkenntnisse
gewinnen garantiert dadurch eigentlich
dass genau das nicht eintreffen wird
da hat sie wahrscheinlich recht was
wirklich zählt ist die leidenschaft und
das interesse und nicht dass sie
irgendwie herausragendes zu leisten das
kommt dann sowieso von selbst wenn wir
dann tatsächlich bahnbrechendes
entdecken sollte oder spektakuläre
theorien aufstellt erfordert das
natürlich hier der bedarf nicht mehr
drücken wir hier ein aber aufs auge
unvergesslich dem auf die glocke denn
nur dann werdet ihr auch über neue
videos informiert und bekommt
nachrichten wie clixoom hat
einschneidende lautet ja ihr geht es
weiter mit unseren besten videos in
einer playlist vollkommen neu
zusammengestellt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran